hey guys welcome back to awesome build
and this week we're going to be doing a
little behind-the-scenes of our prep for
the Suicide Squad review doug had a huge
list of things that he needed for this
review fortunately most of it was were
things that I could find I didn't
necessarily at the build because we had
so much stuff to get ready and prep for
this review but also I did have a little
bit more time at about a week to collect
or find or make any of the little things
that we needed but the like I said the
laundry list of things that we needed
was pretty long I think it was like 17
costumes 13 or 14 specific props and
then to set pieces created specifically
for a couple of scenes that were going
to be shooting so there was quite a lot
that we kind of had to gather up and
stuff fortunately a lot of things I do
have or had parts of that I could kind
of throw together and then there were a
lot of things that I needed to either
order or go find I did do a lot of drive
around to you different thrift stores
and costume shops and and joke shops and
stuff like that to try and collect as
much of the stuff as I could and then a
few things we had to kind of make real
quick but for the most part this is
going to be kind of looking at just the
items that we had to gather up and get
ready for because on the day of it's
going to be a couple of days of filming
actually for this review and I'm going
to be in this review quite a bit so
we're going to try and shoot my scenes
there's going to be a lot of heavy
makeup and costuming and stuff like that
for this review so we're going to try
and shoot allow my scenes early and
later so that and the middle there I
have plenty of time to view the makeup
and costumes and any kind of props and
stuff like that that we might need
during filming so come on we'll take a
look at some of the stuff that we've got
set up already and yeah
[Music]
all right so the list of things that
Doug sent me that he needs rs5 Jim
costumes Joker outfit for me and also a
tux for the Joker and later scenes
Deadshot costume for Malcolm gangster
outfit for Rob Batman outfit for Doug
preferably the Batman vs Superman flash
outfit for Walter a Wonder Woman outfit
for Tamra
Deadshot's little daughter costume for
Malcolm Captain Boomerang for Brian
Diablo outfit for Walter and Chan Tris
outfit for Heather katana costume for
Tamara Slipknot costume for either
Walter Orlando a putty costume from
Power Rangers Diablos headdress for
money turns into a big monster guy a
bill costume for Malcolm three cap
uniforms so that's it for costumes and
unfortunately a lot of the stuff I have
or I have elements of it now props
number one anal beads yeah
all right to a binder that has info on
the Suicide Squad simply labeled nuts
he'll bring the inside pages a boomerang
Rob Dino masks Harley Quinn trading card
a hard hat a dead mouse a knife
preferably steak because it's going to
be weaved around in people's faces a
katana sword
preferably fake because it's going to be
getting slung around a name tag that
says Rick a microphone for a reporter
and a dancing hula doll that sits on a
dashboard so that's not too bad a lot of
that stuff I have or I can find
relatively easily settings and so we're
going to be trying to recreate two
scenes in this film from like a cafe
scene or a restaurant scene and a bar
scene so it just needs to set pieces
that you can shoot instead of having to
do a green-screen because it's going to
be a lot of editing and stuff you want
to shoot fast so we're going to try and
create to sort of set pieces that kind
of mimic those specific scenes and they
don't have to be super elaborate they
just have to give kind of a general idea
because the shots are going to be pretty
simple so so yeah it's a lot of stuff
but most of it are things I think I can
find or alter relatively easily there
are some things I'm probably to go out
and get and stuff like that but there
are a lot of things that we already have
in-house and those things that kind of
already start to collect so let's go
over something to cut some stuff we have
in stack all right so a few easy ones
we've got the Batman costume I did buy a
new Batman belt because I actually used
the belt that we were using for
something else
the Harley Quinn t-shirt the rest of the
costume I believe Ayane has I had as we
playing Harley Quinn just there's a
little shoulder holes around there and
just pretty much good to go
the Wonder Woman costume we've gotten a
ton use out of and I've got a couple of
different versions now of that so
depending on I guess to look that Doug
wants to go for
over here all right so Deadshot I just
got a red shirt with one of our vests
with the blade kind of foam that I am a
when the blade best basically with some
shin guards
so his wrist guns actually are just Iron
Man like toy wrist guns that we actually
had left over from our first snider
invideo that we did so I just kind of
paint a black stripe down him to make a
move a little bit different and what
kind of funding if they just looked like
joy Iron Man risk guns so that's
basically it I also have the masks but
I'm not sure of Doug necessarily wants
to use it and also I'm going to need
probably a bald cap for Malcolm and so
again depending on that's what they want
to go with the mass where they want to
go with the bald cap I'm going to need
like a prosthetic beard and the bald cap
and everything it's going to be a lot of
makeup on the day of filming so kind of
depends how much time and stuff Doug
wants to focus on it but I will have to
get those elements just in case also
enchantress is going to be played by
Heather and I want everyone to feel
comfortable so I actually had other go
find some tights and and a shirt and
stuff like that that she felt
comfortable in that was kind of like a
flesh-colored nude colored and then I
will add illness to that I've got some
netting I've got this sleeved netting
that I got an American science and
surplus to kind of go on her arms I've
got different kind of netting and stuff
like that to drape around her and we'll
tattoo you know do some fake tattoos and
silly tattoos and stuff like that on the
actual garment so that I don't have to
paint her up and tattoo her and stuff as
much so I'll just have to do some makeup
with her face and her hair and
everything like that so it'll be less
involved on the day of filming and stuff
so those are those elements we do have
plenty of police uniforms I have a bunch
of cop uniforms stuff like that so those
arms back flip snap costume is just one
of our best
swift some ropes attached to it pretty
easy and then yeah so we do have a
boomerang and a big coat that we kind of
use for like a I call it the bane coat
but yeah a big furry lined coat and
inside whatever tenifer the boomerang
and those are the omens I have so far
also I think for when Malcolm plays his
daughter I think she's wearing like a
fur coat and stuff like that I do a fur
coat we can put on them and then just
give him like braids or something like
that to make them look I guess more like
a little girl so let's go to some of the
props and stuff that we have so Tamara
is actually doing her katana costume
she's going to do a tutorial on her
channel which you can find the link
below and check that out she did an
amazing job it came out awesome I think
the only elements that she needed were
the mask and the katana so so I did find
a mask I was originally going to make
one but then I found one pretty cheap
that looks pretty good
at a costume place online and so just
ordered it and then just a cheap toy
katana that I covered with aluminum tape
to kind of give it a look of a real
blade sort of and that's that anal beads
I just bought a cheap like dollar store
bracelet had big beads on it and Barney
restrung it and put a ring on the end
apparently these what anal beads look
like fortunately he's an expert and I
was able to put that together also a
dead mouse I actually had a hard time
finding a dead mouse I went to fantasy
casters which is a huge costume store in
Chicago and it's like a block-long it's
like super huge they have tons of stuff
usually they have everything I need
if I'm looking for something I can't
find or whatever but they didn't really
have any dead mice or little mice props
or anything like that they had some rat
stuff like that but they were all too
big I didn't really look like what Doug
was looking for so the closest thing I
could find was at a pet store I found a
bin full of these little toy cat cat toy
mice looks pretty close I had to add you
know legs and stuff like that to it and
kind of paint it up a little bit to make
it look a little bit more like a mouse
but hopefully depending on how Doug
shoots it it will work out
I'm also Barney did the binder with nuts
on it he also gave Doug the option if
they wanted to say mixed nuts so it's
got two options also Barney is going to
be handling the name tag for Rick and
the Harlequin trading cards I can't wait
to see how that turned out also I had to
order this online I thought I'd be able
to find one very easily so when Doug
originally came to meeting said that he
wanted Heather to play in tranches and
when she does like the hula dance he's
like I'm not going to do yet if I'm
going to add some kind of CG or I don't
know a tie guy I'm not really sure I'm
going to shoot it but I want to look
kind of ridiculous so I just suggested
why we just get a dashboard hula girl
and just shake it front of a blue screen
then just put that in for that sequence
so I said that that would be funny and
easy enough to do and I thought it'd be
easy enough to find one of these but I
couldn't so I wound up just ordering one
ordering one online and whatever that
would be enough but so for the set
pieces the restaurant sequence and the
bar sequence were actually going to film
on our main set because we already have
the lights and stuff set up and the
walls everything our dark it's easy to
kind of set up some shots if we need to
and shoot it practically so that Doug
doesn't have to do with green screen we
can we can shoot it do kind of a shallow
depth of field and leave the background
a little dark so that we don't really we
just get a hint of things that are going
on back there so I just hung some
curtains
and some fake windows to kind of give
the illusion but in the background that
they're in the restaurant you know you
add some ambient noise and stuff like
that to and all kind of helps give the
illusion
so hopefully that works out I don't know
we kind of did some tests and it seemed
to look ok so kind of depends on how
Doug wants to shoot it - we may have to
move some things around but ya know
we'll find out so now on this side I
just we put some batten lights behind
this structure with blue lights in them
so it's going to shine up let you
luminate the back wall it kind of gives
a really kind of cool blue light effect
and then I made these orbs just out of
some cheap LEDs hanging from string
whatever just to kind of give it another
extra look so the two lights against the
black background with the blue light
shining up and stuff like that some
splash of color I think will give the
illusion that they're in kind of like a
a bar or a nightclub or something like
that so again it's only for like a
couple of shots that they're going to
need it for it's just to give it a
little bit of a look it's going to be
sort of out of focus so that way we can
just shoot it practically again and duck
and edit it quicker so we don't get the
opportunity to shoot a lot of set pieces
like practically we've been doing a
little bit more and more we're actually
one other sequence we're going to film
practically is inside the helicopter so
we're going to use the corridor that I
built so we can do that practically also
but these pieces were it was kind of fun
to set these up and set up the shots
that kind of play with some lighting and
stuff like that Barney came in and the
two of us kind of like we hung the
drapes we hung the lights and stuff like
that and kind of you know played around
with it you know turning a good thing we
kind of played around with stuff and you
know change lighting and stuff like that
and so I was cool I'm excited to see how
it comes out and see how well it looks
all right so that's kind of it for the
things that we have ready to go the rest
of its going to be on the days of
filming so
I'm going to have to play the Joker so
I'm we had to do makeup and stuff like
that and I played the character before
which is why Doug wanted me to play the
character again but because I'm redoing
a lot of scenes and stuff like that I
got a decent wig and I bought some
actual metal teeth and I've never used
them before so it'll be interesting to
see how that turns out um but aside from
that we're going to be doing a lot of
makeup and costuming and stuff like that
on the day of and that I never really
know how it's going to turn out until
we're in the midst of it so yeah we'll
just see what happened alright so that's
it for this element of it we're going to
start filming and a few hours and today
and tomorrow all right see how it goes
alright so on the day of filming things
went really well but there are some
things that didn't quite work out the
way you know we expected or that I
anticipated so that when I was asked to
play the Joker
don't come to me because I played the
character before we did the first
measuring video and when we did at that
time just I just taken tin foil and put
it in my teeth and because I really
didn't have very many lines while I had
that in my mouth and stuff like that to
look fine I think it worked out fine but
it was still kind of hard to talk and I
kept falling out and stuff like that so
in anticipation of that I went online
and I went to a place called groove and
purchased some fake metal teeth or fake
grille you know there's like a whack
almost like a waxy material kind of
piece that you heat up and then you
place it in the the grille and pop it on
your your teeth or whatever and it sets
and forms around your actual teeth and
that worked out once I got that once I
get heated it up enough I did do it a
few times to kind of of course once I
got it to fit and it looked okay and
everything I would deliver a few lines
and then it would fall out so we tried
several times to do it and I went back
to even trying to do the foil but
everything it was hard to keep it in my
mouth without it falling out and we
didn't have really a lot of time to come
up with a solution so we that's why we
wrote in the joke that I just might
either fail falling out or the grill
falling out and actually Doug says that
my actual teeth were scarier anyway so I
guess that's a compliment also I did
purchase a bald cap for Malcolm that we
were going to apply on the day of
filming also I did purchase a bald cap
for Malcolm that we were going to apply
on the day of however Malcolm is hello
particular about about his his hair and
it does say kind of high up on his head
we were going to have to really flatten
it down it was going to take some time
to apply the bald cap with the
prosthetic and stuff and add the latex
and everything and blend it all in and
then we had to add the beard and
everything so we kind of again came up
with the idea of just putting we had a
wig cap that was a dark brown kind of
wig cap that I put on initially there
kind of flatten his hair down and stuff
like that to see how would look and
basically we just decided that that
combined with just keeping the mask on
but like pulled up would alleviate
having to apply the prosthetic basically
so it did save a lot of time on
production cuff like that and you know
in Ridgid li t we were going to have a
the prosthetic beard I had a fake beer
that I was going to apply we started to
apply it actually that was part of it we
put the beard on but it looked kind of
fake and again it was going to take some
time to get and get it all to look right
and you know we hadn't tested any of
this stuff I never really get a chance
to test any of the makeup out or the
costumes or anything really until the
day of filming so I never know exactly
how things are going to work out or how
things are going to look so we decided
to scrap the beard and I just used
makeup to darken his face to make it
look like he had
and actually I really had that looked
probably better and little less
distracting than a fake looking beard so
also for Heather's character for the
enchantress character I had purchased
some different jewelry and stuff like
that some costume jewelry and just some
cheap jewelry and I had some stuff here
from just lying around that we had left
over from other costumes or that we had
in props and stuff like that that we're
going to use to kind of jazz up the
costume a little bit and Heather
actually came in I'm a day off with all
this jewelry that she found really
really cheap and it was perfect and
actually worked out great so we want to
be using all of that and really thought
that all of the elements of that costume
really came together great because of
Heather really put a lot into it it was
great that camera was taking care of her
character she really wanted to do to
make that costume and it came out really
really great which and again made it so
much easier on me is one less costume to
have to focus on and worry about and
also with Ayanna
you know I went to pick up Ayanna from
the Train to bring her on set and she
walked off the train and Harley I mean
she had put up all her she had done her
makeup in her hair and everything on the
train she had some of the costume you
know she hadn't brought it with her and
stuff like that and then I just
basically supplies a shirt and holster
and the bat and stuff like that but you
know she came kind of already and makeup
are you ready to go so on the shoes like
this like when I have to do costumes and
makeup and I'm also playing a character
and I have to work one of the cameras
and to do stuff behind the scenes it
does get to be quite a bit so it's great
when everybody kind of pitches in and
stuff like that unfortunately usually
sometimes Barney is here and Barney
comes in and gives me a hand stuff like
that unfortunately Barney was sick that
day and couldn't come in while we were
filming and stuff like that so you know
it did it helped greatly that you know
Ayanna and Heather and and Tamra were
able to put so much effort into their
own costumes and their maid
and everything it really helped out on
set and on the day of so so I just
wanted to give you a little shout out so
you guys are awesome
and thanks so much for helping me out
alright guys well thanks so much for
tuning in to this special episode of
awesome bill where we've been looking at
a little bit of the what went into the
Suicide Squad review if you guys want to
see more behind the scenes of the
Suicide Squad review go ahead and check
out the making of nostalgia critic
suicide review also you can check out
the Suicide Squad review bloopers which
is a lot of fun so once again thanks so
much guys for tuning in I hope you guys
found this somewhat enjoyable and/or
entertaining and yeah I'll see you next
time thanks so much for watching
[Music]
you